foreign
[Music]
s of years our Notions about the deepest
parts of the Seas were built upon
guesswork and myths we assumed that
beyond the reach of sunlight the deep
ocean was a cold dark planet of
nothingness but stunning advances in
submersibles and Robotics are now
allowing scientists and explorers their
first real access to Earth's final
frontier and revealing that our old
vision of the deep was wrong oh my gosh
that's amazing oh that's so awesome Hi
friend that is cute oh that's fantastic
the oceans host a world of mountains
rivers caves Vents and a wealth of
exotic forms of life
foreign
[Music]
there now we know all this even though
only about 20 percent of the ocean floor
has yet been mapped and so scientists
are intent on mapping the entire ocean
depths as they anticipate revealing
Untold Mysteries and Rich wonders
tonight we have three Extraordinary
People to tell us about some of those
wonders as we journey together to the
remarkable world of the deep
our first guest is Dr Helen scales who
teaches marine biology at Cambridge
University where she completed her
doctorate her work is focused on the
extraordinary biodiversity of the deep
she writes and lectures on the
inhabitants of Earth's most remote and
mysterious places and her most recent
book is entitled the brilliant Abyss
welcome Helen next we are pleased to
have Dr Vicki farini who is a senior
research scientist at Columbia
University's Lamont Doherty Earth
Observatory Dr farini has participated
in research Expeditions all over the
world using mapping techniques to
understand the processes that shape the
sea floor in a variety of environments
Dr farini is also the head of the seabed
2030 Regional Center for the Atlantic
and Indian oceans welcome Vicky and
finally we have Victor viscovo who is a
U.S naval command underturned private
Equity investor turned Explorer he was
the first person to reach the bottom of
all of Earth's oceans and has devoted
himself to exploring the deep sea
traveling miles down into the ocean's
deepest trenches blazing a path to
extreme environments that we are just
beginning to understand welcome Victor
and welcome to all of you thanks for
taking the time to have this
conversation about the oceans about the
deepest part of Earth's landscape and I
want to start by just getting a sense of
what drives each of you because you know
I think many of us when we think about
explorers and exploration you know we
have images of of going to mountain tops
or even going into deep space and the
and the seemingly infinite expanse of
stars and galaxies it's really big and
opening and all of you at least for part
of your time now are drawn to the other
direction going deep under the Earth's
Oceans Where It's kind of dark and kind
of enclosed and kind of scary so where
did it start for each of you Helen why
don't you start what Drew you to the
oceans
well I think it
it comes from
those different kind of views that you
get all the Mountaintop of that view of
outer space and and for me I think the
moment I knew that the oceans were going
to be somewhere I wanted to spend more
time was when I put my body into the
ocean and I saw it and I felt it for
myself and I saw this very
restricted view of this space in front
of me but I felt like I was part of it
and somehow entering that
three-dimensional hidden realm that
normally is completely out of sight for
everyone that's what hooked me in it's
like being led into this secret space
and and being shown that another part of
this planet a huge part of this planet
that um is just waiting for us to go see
it yeah for sure Vicky how about you is
this a a long time interest more recent
where does your love of the ocean come
from so I I grew up on the beaches of
Cape Cod and so my childhood was all
about watching the tide roll in and out
and seeing the sea floor revealed for
short periods of time and then covered
up so I think that was part of what
really drove me to it and as my studies
and opportunities sort of presented
themselves I ended up really getting
interested in creating maps of the
seafloor and I have a similar sort of
fascination with trying to see what's
hidden from us by the ocean and also
trying to help others see that through
the data that we collect and put
together and you know I'm really I'm
still waiting for that sensation of
standing on the sea floor and looking at
it as though there's no water there
there have been visualizations put
together but I I don't think it really
does it justice but as we bring more and
more data together and we just look at
these spectacular landforms on the
seafloor it just continues to compel me
to do more and to work with people to
bring this data to Light Victor how
about you
I couldn't help but uh smile when you
mentioned about going to mountain tops
or going to space because I actually
done both those things quite a lot going
into the deep oceans in many respects is
driven by the same curiosity that took
me to all these other places but also
the desire to really push myself to get
to these places which can be very
difficult when you're doing it in person
particularly at the bottom of the ocean
so it's curiosity it's a drive to push
oneself and just to push technological
and other barriers to hopefully see
what's on the other side of that other
Hill I've just been driven by that my
whole life yeah you know I had a kind of
uncomfortable experience with going
under the water I did a scuba dive in
Australia admittedly without any
training and it was pretty silly how
they attempted to train me on the ship
ride out to the dive location so they
pulled me under I got all the equipment
I look up I see this mountain of water
above me and I I really freaked and
panicked I was like you know just
basically get me out of here so I do
Wonder Victor
do you think that we romanticize space
since you've been there because we don't
directly experience but we fear the
oceans and the water because we all have
either direct or indirect
experiences of that Danger
well when you go into space it's
gorgeous you see the curvatur to the
Earth you see stars it's Heavenly what
are the Deep parts of the oceans named
after Hades hell itself
so I mean the hatal Zone but uh I think
human beings are born with an innate
fear of drowning and we're also scared
of the dark and so when you put someone
in the deep ocean I think you're
generating some primordial feels the
fears that we have within ourselves that
uh are difficult to put down except you
know with some discipline as you have
I'm sure hopefully you're still scuba
diving yeah no I will I will never do it
again uh but but I gather you know for
someone who's gone to the mountaintops
and gone into space
do you know no fear I mean are there
things that scare you no fear fear is
very useful Fear Can sharpen your senses
and make you aware of danger but it can
be controlled with practice you know I
learned how to be a pilot when I was 19
and you just go through enough things in
your life that you learn to be able just
to put it aside and deal with the issues
and certainly not panic yeah well maybe
I'll need more training maybe we can
talk after uh this discussion but uh but
with that let's turn to just get a sense
of
the lay of the land which is kind of the
opposite of an opposite metaphor as our
journey is not through land it's through
water but even so Helen can you give us
a just sort of an overarching sense of
of the various zones that we would pass
through or that you all pass through in
these kinds of Journeys from the surface
of the ocean right down to its deepest
locations
absolutely I mean I think
um the beginning point in understanding
what's going on in the ocean and the
deep ocean is just to wrap your head
around the size of it this is the single
biggest living space on our planet
um and a big part of that is its depth
right um and the way I often it just
describe it is to say well hey look I'm
going to take a like a normal glass
marble like this one we're going to sail
off to some place
um where there's very deep ocean beneath
us and I'm just going to drop that over
the side of the ship and and then we can
just imagine that it's going to pass
down on this journey down into the
deeper parts of the of the sea and as it
goes it's going to pass through these
different different zones which we give
names based on the various the changing
conditions that you're going to get in
those zones so for the first six and a
half seven minutes it's gonna pass
through what we call the sunlit zone
that top bit that you can see at the top
of this this diagram here and that's the
bit of the ocean we know the best that's
the surfaces the place where the sun
still shines
um where most of what we know about life
in the ocean as well is it's what we use
it's where we go it's where we dive all
those kind of things
um so that's just the very top bit six
seven minutes then our marble is going
to enter the deep ocean for real like
what most scientists agree this is where
the deep ocean really begins is around
the 200 meter Mark so that's the
beginning of what we call the Twilight
Zone there is still some sunlight at
this point but it's this blue deep Inky
color
um you know go out on a clear night at
Twilight and look up to the sky and
you'll see that like that beautiful kind
of color that's sort of what most of the
Twilight is like all of the time during
the day this very dim light and the key
thing and I'm sure we'll come back to
this is that's not enough light to drive
photosynthesis so there's not enough
light to power the Machinery the solar
power Machinery of most ecosystems so
um so there's no new food being made
um that twilight zone is going to go
from 200 meters down to about a thousand
meters that big thick layer the marble
takes um I think it's around about about
half an hour to pass through that that
thick Zone that deep zone of The
Twilight Zone and you know it's a it's a
graded thing but it'll finally get to
the point where there's no sunlight at
all and this is what we call the
midnight zone we're getting deeper down
into that next layer of the ocean and
it's permanent midnight it's it's like
walking out in the middle of the night
style a style at moonless night
um uh from a thousand meters down and
that big thick chunk goes down that
layer goes down to about 4 000 meters
and I think it's another hour and a half
or something like that for the Marvel to
go foreign now
um the average ocean depth is around
about the 4 000 meter mark But there are
places that go very much deeper and
Victor has been to those places so if
we're very careful with the the aim of
my marble it's going to drop down into
the abyss and eventually potentially
into a an oceanic trench and those are
the very very deepest parts
um of the ocean I think there's 40
something of them in various parts this
is where we've got the edges of tectonic
plates are kind of coming together
pulling apart and forming these dig
v-shaped cousins if we get to the bottom
of the very deepest one our Marble's
going to take something like six hours
to reach the bottom passing through that
that Hazel Zone that Victor already
mentioned
um uh and that really you know that is
getting us to the very the very bottom
down there in in these Oceanic trenches
um so yeah you've got these layers
different conditions are changing the
pressure of course is ramping up and the
temperature's dropping all sorts of the
physical and chemical conditions are
shifting as we're going down from the
surface layer down into the deepest can
you give us a sense of the volume I mean
the amount of water is there a way to
give a feel for that so again thinking
about this for 2
60 feet mark down to the bottom
volume is is ridiculously big um I think
it's something like a is it a billion
cubic kilometers something like that
yeah it's an astonishingly
big volume it really is this is why we
can safely say that something like 95
plus percent of the biosphere the living
space on our planet
is the deep ocean so yeah it's it's it's
hard to wrap your head around that but
but try yeah and Victor someone who has
traveled all the way to the deepest
parts I mean
um There Are Places on planet Earth and
I've been to a few of them that really
feel like you're on a different planet
which is kind of an exciting thing even
if you're on the surface is that what it
feels like to descend do you feel like
you are entering a different Universe
relative to the one that we normally
inhabit
oh absolutely when you strap yourself
into this two-person submersible that
I've been operating for the last four
years you feel like you're in a Space
Capsule and you have these small portals
you're descending into 1100 bar of
pressure which is 1100 times the
difference between going from the
surface of the Earth to outer space the
pressures are insane it's a very
dangerous place in many respects but
when you're down at the bottom you're
seeing an environment that only very
specialized life can exist in we see
bacterial mats on rocks we see tendrils
of small creatures living in these
extraordinary environments and I've said
too many people that if we find life on
other planets it'll look a lot more like
what we're finding in the ultra deep
oceans than you find on land and I think
that's very true and so that's why it
makes it very special to go to all these
different trenches trying to find out if
they're different if they're the same in
doing a bit of science that hopefully
can yield insights into what we may find
up in space and so you know you
mentioned in space and climbing
mountains which I presume you did
because of the Allure of of just you
know being an explorer
is that your state of mind when you
travel to the ocean depths or are you
have you shifted more into a a research
and and science mode where are you at
mentally in these Journeys
well certainly spending a lot of time
around uh doctors Vicki and Dr Helen and
others it certainly makes you want to
become more educated and you'd certainly
get more interested I know we've done
enormous amount of mapping for jebco
which Vicki is a part of we've worked
with other scientists to help discover
new species but for me it's been
interesting because the three different
experiences space mountaineering in the
Deep oceans are in a way kind of three
parts of a triangle they're all very
different but they all have the same
elements where you're driven by
curiosity and it takes different
capabilities to do those three things
mountain climbing is incredibly visceral
violent physical going to space is very
rapid and beautiful but you're basically
strapping yourself to a 10-story
explosive device going to the ocean is
much more quiet when you get to the
bottom it feels much more ancient and so
they're all very different emotions when
you do these three things but they all
have the same strand of satisfying
humans innate desire to explore and be
curious yeah
amazing sounds wonderful I wish I wasn't
so terrified maybe I'd do it one day so
Vicki when we um when we when we turn to
the the ocean floor we're turning to
some of the science that you have put a
lot of effort into developing so can you
give us a sense of what it's like there
on the bottom because I think many of us
have an incorrect image right I think
many of us have an image that you get to
the bottom it's like a big beach a big
underwater Beach it's just flat and
Sandy and then that's all that's there
but we've already heard about these
trenches can you give us a sense of what
is down there at the bottom of the ocean
yeah I mean I think we're still just
starting to uncover that and and reveal
that to uh to ourselves into the world
and as we get more and more data I think
we're really surprised at what we find
and in many cases
um but in my own exploration of data
that has been made available I can tell
you about these spectacular Meandering
rivers on the sea floor that look just
like rivers on land uh they're fed Often
by rivers from land that flow into the
ocean there are giant ripples on the sea
floor in various places one of my
favorite examples of that is in the
Argentine Basin in the South West
Atlantic there are ripples that look
just like the kinds of ripples we see on
beaches but they're 100 meters tall
so if you think about the size of that
like it's really quite spectacular
um and there's all sorts of evidence of
processes at work physical processes and
biological processes so as we get more
data and as we start to reveal this you
know we're mapping with sonar so we're
seeing the shape of the sea floor which
is giving us sort of a crude view of
what the land form looks like but when
we go to the bottom in submersibles or
deploy cameras or robots to the bottom
and start to get eyes on the seafloor we
can gather a lot more information about
what's really there that's when we can
see the biological organisms that are
there the little ecosystems little
because they're not little but in your
mind in some ways they are because it's
kind of like you're looking through a
straw right your your view of the
seafloor is so small compared to the
magnitude of it
so so Vicki you have um a map of
Manhattan that you sometimes use to give
a sense of the kind of resolution that
you'd love to have versus the kind of
resolution that we do have when it comes
to mapping the sea floor can you just
take us through that
yeah sure I think uh this is part of my
way to communicate with people uh how
little we know about the details of the
seafloor so we're all we've become
accustomed to having literally a map in
the palm of our hands on our smartphones
we can zoom in to our houses or our
friends houses and see individual cars
um so I have this map from Google Earth
that shows uh where the UN is in
Manhattan and I'm not even zoomed all
the way in but it shows the kind of
detail that we're accustomed to and I
just have a series of images here that
show the kinds of the scale of the kinds
of resolution that we're talking about
with ocean mapping so first starting
with what a 100 meter resolution grid
would look like then moving out to what
a 200 meter resolution grid would look
like then a 400 meter and then 800 and
so the idea here is you know just to
help us understand the kinds of detail
that we gain by having the higher
resolution data but also really the
limits of what a 100 meter resolution
grade is with respect to what we're used
to seeing with our own eyes and I think
it's really important to try to remember
and wrap our heads around again the size
of the ocean right it covers more than
70 percent of the planet so there's this
huge portion of our planet that's
completely hidden from us by water the
sea floor itself and everything in that
water column that we were just talking
about it's just there's so much to
discover and to reveal and so those
measurements that you take are they are
those robotic systems or do you rely on
on on Victor going down and actually
having a human being then how important
is it having a live person I don't mean
lie versus dead but how important is it
having someone who's really piloting the
craft when you're when you're trying to
understand the the bottom of the ocean
so the way that we start to reveal the
shape of the sea floor is tip and
particularly in a deep sea uh usually
starts with ship-based sonar and Victor
has a ship based sonar on his ship and
uh as he mentioned that data has been
coming into the global synthesis that
we're curating for the world so that
gives us a crude representation because
the way I like to think about it is it's
like a flashlight right so if you're
close to the wall with your flashlight
it's Illuminating a small area as you
pull away it gets bigger that's sort of
how the Sound Works that we transmit
from the ship so we get you know a
fairly large area covered when we're
using a ship-based sonar we can take
sonars closer to the sea floor so again
we'll get closer that cone will get
tighter we can see in more detail the
the shape of the sea floor but once we
get eyes on the seafloor whether it's
humans or through a camera that's when
we really start to understand what we're
looking at we can make some inference
based on the shape we can make some
inference based on the hardness which we
can measure with the sonar signal itself
but getting eyes on the sea floor is
really when a lot of the real detailed
Discovery happens and so at the
resolution that you want to realize that
dream that you mentioned before that
you'd be able to stand on the sea floor
and have an accurate rendition I don't
know if you imagine that virtual reality
or something like that at that level of
resolution of mapping what percent of
the sea floor have we mapped so far
so the best estimates of
um how much of the ocean has been mapped
through the lens of this International
project that we're working on the nibbon
foundation Jeb cocbed 2030 project uh
most recent number that just came out is
just over 23 24 so about a quarter of
the ocean has been mapped but you have
to remember that the resolution in that
Global synthesis is much coarser than
what we see with our eyes the highest
resolution that we are
aspiring to achieve for this synthesis
partly driven by the desire to do this
quickly we can certainly get higher
resolution than our goals but to sort of
level the the the
the metrics that we want to try to
achieve and make it achievable the
highest resolution we're aiming for is
100 meter resolution so that's the size
of a football field so that's one
vertical measurement for the size of a
football field and that's in the
shallowest water of 1500 meters depth to
the coastline as we move into deeper
water we're aspiring for 400 meters and
the majority of the ocean and a little
bit coarser of 800 meters in in the very
deepest depths the places where Victor
has gone himself and again this is
really driven by the technology that's
out there that's most uh distributed
around the world and also it's partly
driven by how surveying the seafloor
works right so what we use is typically
multi-beam sonar which creates a fan of
sound beams and typically we get four
maybe five times the water depth covered
as a profile as the ship moves along so
when we're in deep water Imaging from
the surface we cover a very large area
if we're in 2 km meters will get eight
kilometers across if we're in shallow
water that's implicitly much much
smaller we have to go back and forth
many more times and so we we came up
with some goals that we believe are
achievable particularly if we bring the
whole world together and and mobilize
all the resources that exist but we
fully recognize that the technology and
the desire to map at much higher
resolution is there I myself have mapped
and visited parts of the seafloor that
are two and a half kilometers deep and
the maps that I've made at that those
sites are less than a meter in
resolution so you can see the kind of
detail of like a desk right the things
are in the room that you're sitting in
WoW less than a medium resolution that's
amazing so Helen I'm going to come to
you in a second I want you to take us
through the kind of life forms that we
would see during this December first
victim I just want to turn to you for a
moment because I just want to get a
sense of the the history of these deep
Dives I guess one of the earliest Dives
to the bottom of the Challenger Deep was
I think in the 1960s or so and then
James Cameron did his thing and in 2012.
what has happened since and and are you
the record holder and how many times
have you gone down to the deepest parts
Captain Don Walsh and Jacques Ricard
went down in 1916 in The Trieste they
were the first ones at the bottom of the
Mariana Trench Challenger Deep and then
James Cameron went in 2012 in his
deepsea Challenger neither of those
submersibles ever went back down again
it's a pretty harsh environment requires
a lot of Maintenance and some design
changes so in 2019 I took down the
limiting factor my submersible and I've
now been down 15 times so that's in
addition to other devotion trenches as
well ten thousand meter plus all over
the world there are four of them and
we've now visited all of them
and so before we started diving only
three people have been to the bottom of
the ocean fewer people than it actually
walked on the moon and I'm happy to say
that through all of our activities in
the last four years we've now taken more
than 25 people down so much more people
than I walked on the moon the Chinese
have their deep diving submersible
defend Jew I believe that they've taken
down at least 5 10 or even more people
down so I think we've seen an explosion
of access to the deep sea floor which
was my mission from the very beginning
which was to develop the technology to
allow human beings to reliably
repeatedly and safely visit any point on
the seafloor to open up that door to
exploration and we've continued the
technological advancements in fact just
three weeks ago we took the first side
scan sonar which would allow resolution
of mapping of the sea floor even at full
ocean depth or the bottom of Challenger
Deep with less than one meter resolution
which simply had not existed before so
we'll continue to try and press the
envelope technologically to allow the
these discoveries to continue so we're
going to turn to the technology that you
have developed with your partners has
allowed this to happen in just a little
while but but Helen why don't you give
us a sense of what life forms look like
at the various depths because I think in
the end of the day that's really a big
part of the appeal of trying to
understand the Earth and why don't you
start by first telling us you made this
interesting statement that the majority
of Earth's biomass I guess animal
biomass is in the oceans which is a
remarkable statement and that is correct
um certainly the yeah I mean I think the
biomass as well as the the biosphere the
living space without any doubt this is
the biggest the volume if you like of
the ocean is the biggest occupiable
space that we have but in terms of
biomass too I mean there's some
extraordinary things that we're finding
in the deep ocean and I should should
begin this by reminding you all that
um it wasn't not that long ago when when
you know the cutting-edge science maybe
150 years ago genuinely thought that
life ran out uh at depth you know that
it petered out to nothing the azoic
theory is what it was called and it
really was very persuasive there was
that what seemed to be data to back that
up dredging data of animals pulled up
from different depths and it just seem
to run out now there's various reasons
why that wasn't actually the best data
to be using they were going to places
where life does run out because it does
in some places that's not not enough
going on in the surface Seas to kind of
power life further down but the point is
that now we know that life goes all the
way to the very bottom and Victoria I'm
sure has seen that life in these deepest
depths but what we know also is that in
those zones I've been describing there's
different types of of species adapting
to these extraordinary conditions as
they're going down and in terms of like
the volume the the actual living Mass
the biomass of organisms one of the
really
um really cool and extraordinarily
abundant groups of animals we know of
occupy the Twilight Zone and these are
collectively known as lantern fish
um and bristle males there's a few
basically a few little little fish they
look like sardines with with big eyes
the differences that they can glow in
the dark as does an awful lot of life in
the deep ocean which I'll come to
um but we do think that these are
probably the most abundant uh well we
know that these are the most abundant
vertebrates on the planet there are
trillions of these things the estimate
used to be that there were maybe around
a gigaton of them that's been revised up
to somewhere between 10 and 20 gigatons
um they you know they rival domestic
chickens uh they exceed domestic
chickens in terms of their absolute
numbers and these things now then first
there's loads of different species some
of them seem to communicate with each
other with those lights that they have
those are patches of of bioluminescence
which they're using we think possibly as
communication also to hide and this is
one thing a lot of organisms are doing a
lot of animals are doing in that Inky
twilight zone is they're trying to find
some way of hiding themselves when
there's nothing to hide behind this is
this massive three-dimensional space
open pelagic water nothing to hide
behind plenty of things trying to eat
you so um one way of doing that and
these lantern fish do it brilliantly is
basically give themselves a cloak of
invisibility they they have this
bioluminescence which is focused on
their ventral surface on their bellies
and um and the light they create it's
either
um a bacteria that lives in their
tissues or they actually have their
their own ability to make these chemical
reactions which create light
um they match that color of the water
around them that deep blue and so it's
like they're hiding their silhouette or
they're messing with their silhouette so
they look less like a dark little fish
swimming above the Predator looking up
towards the surface seeing these these
Shoals of super abundant fish and we see
this in lots of other species too there
are there's a whole bunch of of
different ways of what we call counter
illumination and that's one way of
surviving because one thing I would say
about life in the deep ocean like we
know there's there's plenty of it it's
hugely diverse but it's tough it's tough
living in the it when there's you know
there's there's not a whole bunch of of
food around it's a very hungry place
it's a very lonely place it's big
um finding mates uh finding food is
difficult and so what we see are all
these amazing adaptations to to those
challenges that come uh with living in
this huge Depot especially the open
Waters of the deep especially you know
it's like wandering around in the
Twilight Zone is is quite a big deal and
I should say these lantern fish are
really important as well just simply by
being there and they do move around they
swim up to the surface at night to feed
and then they swim back down into the
Twilight Zone bringing carbon from the
deep and and acting it into Waters where
it's going to stay they form a really
important part of the climate system
that the ocean is playing in the
biological systems are feeding into that
um and they get eaten by a whole bunch
of other things too super important
thing what role does Maureen Snow Play
in this so I guess even some people call
this ocean dandruff I guess not as as
nicer a euphonious term but uh is that
part of the ecosystem and the way in
which these animals feed
so yeah Marine snow is what powers most
of life in the deep ocean with some
exceptions which again will I'm sure
will come to but basically this it's
Marines know it sounds lovely it's that
white uh Flex that you see in those film
clips down in the deep ocean
um it's the it's kept particles catching
light on video it's mainly
um made up of organic matter from the
surface in the form of dead Plankton
tiny little creatures that are up there
as they fall down dead
um also their feces Clump together into
these particles they do look like fluffy
snow
um and this is the prime source of
energy and carbon that's getting into
the deep ocean
um and it's a thin trickle it's a
constant trickle it's actually seasonal
as well you might think just because
it's dark down in the Deep it's like you
know the same all year round but you do
get blooms of Plankton in the surface
seeds which make their way into the deep
that will affect the input of food and
so what you're getting what we're
getting in the animals living through
that open water column and on the sea
floor as well a lot of animals that eat
Marine snow you've got shrimp that that
have incredible
um long feelers on their legs that just
comb the water and catch snow you've got
jellyfish that just that send out use
their bodies basically as Nets
um amazing animals that produce sort of
sticky mucus Nets to to catch this
Marine snow and then they bring it in
and feed it one of my favorites is the
um uh the vampire squid they look really
terrifying these animals they're they're
small bright blood red
um squid they look real look they should
be Predators but they're gentle snow
catchers they they out they reel out
these long filaments again and they just
sit there in the water waiting for this
rain of of thin this thin rain of carbon
to come down and they collect these
particles of snow pack them into
snowballs uh with the with the hooks on
their arms and then they eat them so
they're snow eaters and that's what we
see a lot of the time living in the deep
is about finding ways of catching this
thin rain of energy
um and and using as little energy as you
can as well that's you know you've got
to be as efficient as possible when
there's not much food around and that's
why we see a lot of um incredibly
delicate looking creatures in the deep
ocean which kind of goes against what
you might think you know this is a place
of immense pressure
um it's a tough place to live and yet
what we see are delicate jellyfish of
All Sorts which actually lots of
different types of um of animals we call
them jellyfish they're made of jelly and
it's a winning strategy
Jelly's basically a very thin uh it's
it's just water and a bit of protein
basically a bit of collagen that's
essentially what it is but it allows an
organism to make a body very cheaply and
run it very cheaply it's much less
energy required to to float around as a
jellyfish than to power around like a
bluefin tuna with with great big muscles
that need a lot of food and that's
that's why a lot of groups of organisms
that perhaps look very different in
other places
um become gelatinous they're worms swim
through the Open Water of the deep
things like gossamer worms which
relatives are basically earthworms long
distance relatives and they swim in
beautiful pirouettes through the open
Waters of the The Twilight Zone in the
midnight zone and their bodies are again
kind of made made of jelly it helps them
float it makes life easier
um and so so that's why we see life that
is so different I mean Victor talked
about if we found life on other planets
it's likely to resemble things that we
find out in the deep ocean and and I
think this is partly why the conditions
are so different compared to what we
know out here on land and the responses
that Evolution has come up with I've met
that you know that's why we see all
these extraordinary things that we just
couldn't even imagine yeah out here so
so Vicky I just want to get a feel when
you go on a dive and Victor I want to
hear your thought on this too do you
have to look hard to see the kinds of
things that Helen is talking about or is
it just so commonplace so ubiquitous
that that's just the environment all all
the way down
it actually depends all the different
trenches have had a bit of different
character there have been some trenches
I've been where it's been actually quite
difficult to actually see life forms you
know with the naked eye but other times
I've been on sheer Rock faces and rock
is great because it provides a place for
the organisms to actually latch onto and
there are stronger currents typically
around there so there's more food flow
but I've seen colonies of bacterial mats
of tendrils coming out of sea anemones
at 10 000 plus meters and it's just been
extraordinary little colonies that look
unlike anything I've ever seen on the
terrestrial world and so that's why when
we go down and we explore a lot of it
really is a hunt for these more dense
areas so hopefully we find something
different and hopefully of great
interest of Science and Vicky your
experience is it similar to Victor well
I mean sometimes depending on where you
are in the ocean it's chance right so we
know generally what the kinds of
habitats that some fish and jellies
might live in and we might come across
one during a dive there are other places
in the ocean like hydrothermal vents
where we know in many cases what kinds
of organisms we're going to expect to
see there and you know the giant tube
worms for example and the clams and the
mussels and the crabs and shrimp like
they're these really teeming ecosystems
and we know that they're there because
they've been identified previously or we
sense the chemical signatures of these
sites through the water column and we
can get down there and make new
discoveries of new ones but there's um
so I think there's some chance and
there's some prediction depending on the
kinds of environments and how well
they're understood the the really deep
sea that has been largely Out Of Reach
until very recently is some of the most
unknown right because we haven't been
able to get down there so the work that
Victor's been doing and really opening
up access so that others can get to that
part of the ocean and there's other
submersibles that are starting to have
that kind of capability I think are
going to reveal a whole lot of
information to us so that we can start
to make predictions as we we understand
the processes that happen in those
environments
yeah please I was on a dive just a week
ago at 9 000 meters the first human
descent into the Palau trench and as we
were cruising the submersible just off
the bottom we saw a jellyfish with these
two almost meter long tendrils I've
never seen anything like it and yet it
happened so fast as soon as we noticed
it it was gone and we couldn't backtrack
because we would have silted out with
all the different currents and we were
just hoping that the cameras caught it
and it did and it's a low resolution
picture but it just goes to point out
that there can be some very unusual
things down there but you have to be
quick sometimes and you better have the
cameras rolling and so have you
discovered new species in in your dreams
yeah certainly well it would be a
surprise if we didn't because we're
visiting places that have been isolated
evolutionarily for millions of years so
especially when we're looking at micro
level organisms they're going to have a
little bit of genetic drift but we
absolutely have have seen creatures
where literally my chief scientist and I
were standing in the room of our ship
where we look at the video and he looked
at a creature we found in the Java
trench and he said I have no clue what
that is
amazing and so Helen Vicky made
reference in her answer a moment ago the
word gigantic made an appearance and and
I gathered when you get really far down
it's not uncommon to find
oversized animals you know gigantic
animals can you give a sense of of what
some of those are and is there any
insight into why they're so big
yeah deepsea gigantism is kind of fun um
one I've encountered myself well not in
person but through remote Technologies
on an expedition in the Gulf of Mexico
uh are giant isopods
um you know and these are crustaceans
they're um they're more familiar you
would see them out on land um wood lice
here in the UK I think you call them
pill bugs in the US there's little guys
you'd find under plant pots running
around roll up into balls when they're
scared yeah and in the deep ocean
they're the size of um rugby balls or
American footballs and pink and huge
um and uh and one reason we think that
that is and
um and various other sort of bigger than
the normal species we find in the deep
ocean
um it is again it looks better this idea
of it being a hungry place
um these are especially in the case of
these giant isopods they are scavengers
so they are waiting for food to fall
down from above they're crawling across
on the sea floor
um and and when they come across
something big to eat they will eat and
eat and eat and the the bigness if you
like of them is basically like a camel
hump it's a it's a store of of energy
it's a fat reserve and it keeps them
going and um you know people have
brought these things up to the surface
kept them in aquariums
um offered them food and for years and
years they're like nope I'm done I don't
need anything else I'm good for like up
to four years so so yeah so that's
another adaptation to just a hungry
place but also a sporadic place
um I mean one of the things we did in
the Gulf of Mexico was um we put an app
we put some some dead alligators on on
the on the in the abyss on the seabed to
see what would happen to them no one had
done that before it sounds like maybe a
strange thing to do but alligators don't
live in the deep ocean but they do
occasionally we think end up there
um they live in coastal Waters um and
they have been seen
um swept offshore um dead dead
individuals that have come to an end
perhaps after storms and things that get
swept offshore and they will eventually
sink down and so we wanted to know well
what would what would happen to one
uh or some of these these big stores of
energy I mean a big a big alligator is a
big bunch of food for things to eat and
we found a whole bunch of different
things happened uh one was well sure
enough after 24 hours we put this thing
down went back after 24 hours and those
giant eye supports had found the
alligator there was dozens of them
feeding on it um so you know they they
had their dinner for the next four years
sorted out
um and that was great we went back to
um I think the same one and about a
month later that the skeleton was
tripped back and and what we found were
at least two new species of bone-eating
worms so these are deep sea worms that
are that have evolved specifically to
eat this trip back bones of vertebrates
mostly whales that's where they were
first discovered was on Wales
um and we found two new species for the
Gulf of Mexico you put down alligator
and Along come the worms that's one way
of finding species in the deepest is by
looking in the places where you think
there should be more
um and then there was a third one I
should say as well which just
disappeared and we had tied this
alligator to a thick rope and and put a
weight down just in case it got anything
happen to it something came along and
chewed through that rope thick old
plastic rope and made off with our
alligator
um it could have been a big shock we
think possibly maybe a giant squid came
along and took that one too so um so so
that was a lot of fun um but again yeah
feast in the Deep come along and when
they do things like um isopods make the
most of it and I can't help but think
you know as a physicist is part of the
gigantic size just a volume to surface
area issue where you get like a lot of
volume and relatively small surface area
so you're not losing as much energy
through contact with the environment
does that have anything to do with it or
am I just going in an oblique direction
of irrelevance here I don't know it's a
good it's a really good question I mean
you do get other huge things too and one
that Springs to mind
um I guess it it isn't quite that but a
couple of years ago I think off the
coast of Australia they filmed the
longest siphonophore which is a jelly
type creature
um and it was filmed in this amazing
spiral it was just sort of hovering
there in mid-water I think in the
Twilight Zone in this gigantic spa and I
believe it was calculated to be about 30
meters long bigger than anyone ever
found one of these organisms and these
are actually Colonial yeah there we go
there's an image of it
um the colonial organism so it's made up
of lots of individual animals that all
kind of live together in this big long
string
um uh and I can imagine I mean in that
sense being big is helpful if you're
catching this the snow coming down the
more the more of you that you can spread
out and catch that food the better
um but we know very little I think about
this particular individual animal and um
this species and what it does why it's
in that shape I don't think we really
know either
um what it's doing there and what are
the uh what are the lifetimes like do we
have a sense of how long these animals
live
that's the other thing about the deep
ocean is we do find some incredibly
long-lived
I mean the longest live things that we
really really fine I mean a lot of these
are again the colonial organisms like
corals
um there there are many that are
hundreds of years old
um you know colonies of of little polyps
growing together in these sort of flower
like tree-like shapes
um hundreds like centuries old is quite
common for corals living in the deep
ocean I should say yeah we find Corals
in the deep sea that's
um perhaps a surprising thing too you
think of them as building beautiful
reefs like the Barrier Reef you know
shallow tropical species but actually
more than half of the corals we know of
um are live in the deep ocean
um they live very different lives but
they do live down there and some of them
for a very very long time
um the oldest I think are black corals
um so far they've been aged to more than
4 000 years old so a colony that's been
growing like individual polypsa will
grow and die but that same you know that
same bushy looking piece of coral will
have been in that spot
um you know since the time that the the
Pharaohs were building yet pyramids in
Egypt and all that kind of stuff
um same with other things too I mean
he's like Greenland shark we know they
live for about 500 years there are clams
that live in the deep sea for 500 years
or so again I guess this I think does
also link into this this hungry cold
slow pace of life that we find in the
deep ocean you know live for a long time
wait for the next chance for the food to
come along wait for the next mate to
come along there just seems to be this
evolutionary pressure
for life to be long and slow in some
cases big
um and and that's what works down there
I mean that is another one of the
Mysteries that would that scientists are
still trying to figure out like well why
do corals for instance live that long
and how do they do it what is it that
they how are they figuring out not to be
you know succumb to all of the other
reasons why the rest of us age uh much
more quickly and that's you know a lot
of exciting stuff's coming out of that
too so Vicki you mentioned hydrothermal
vents as one of the features that one
encounters way down on the ocean floor
can you just give us a sense of
what those are and and what surprises
they have brought forth as people have
studied them yeah so hydrothermal then
were really discovered in the 1970s so
not so long ago
um and there are places where hot
mineral-laden water is coming out of the
sea floor the minerals precipitate and
form these really spectacular structures
we can image and see the hot water
coming out of the sea floor some of it
has uh basically black smoke they're
called black smokers it looks like black
smoke and organisms are able to use the
minerals that come out of that hot water
as a food source so here these organisms
are on the seafloor far far away from
sunlight and uh they're you know grouped
around these spectacular geologic
features and they're able to live there
and Thrive there and and so you know
Helen in her descent with the marble
made clear that at some point even not
that deep we do lose sunlight which led
some people in the past to conclude that
life would Peter out no sunlight no
photos didn't synthesis and you know the
prevailing thought would be therefore no
energy to give life what it requires to
continue onward but what you're saying I
gather is that there are other ways in
which animals can process the
environment to extract energy and and
that's and that's what we're seeing so
how well do we understand this other
kind of chemical synthesis do we
understand it as well as photosynthesis
so I think that based on the research
that's been done over the past you know
almost 50 years we have a pretty good
understanding of the mechanisms of how
that uh that energy uh Works
chemosynthesis is what it's called right
so prior to that Discovery
photosynthesis was thought to be sort of
the basis of all of the the food web and
life in its most primitive forms we know
that chemosynthesis can happen the
processes are uh you know there's more
being learned all the time about it I
think
um I think one of the most stunning
things about it that really kind of
shakes up your perception of the world
is that the minerals that are being used
in these environments as the basis of
energy are toxic to most other organisms
so these particular organisms are
adapted to use what would other wise be
toxic in this incredibly challenging
difficult environment under pressure
under extreme temperatures and they're
able to live and Thrive there and in my
own experience of visiting these sites
one of the things things that I find
Most Fascinating is the temperature
gradients so there'll be a black smoker
with the hot water coming out of it and
it can be a few hundred degrees Celsius
and you know just a short distance from
it it's like four degrees Celsius and so
those gradients are over very very short
distances which is just kind of a
spectacular reality of it and so Victor
I think you may mention before you've
you've seen these up close and personal
you've you've actually gone down and
seen what's that like
it's extraordinary I think before we
really started diving to the ultra deep
parts of the ocean there is some
evidence of chemosynthesis of bacterial
mats at those extreme depths but since
we've been diving down there so
regularly we've seen them all over the
world in multiple trenches we've seen
beautiful gold colored bacterial match
red even blue in some areas and where we
were able to actually retrieve a sample
of these bacterial mats from you know 10
800 meters and so it has been very
interesting to see this different type
of life in its actual environment and
then in addition to the bacteria Maps
you'll also see these very fine tendrils
that are sifting through the water for
nutrients or other chemicals we're
really not sure actually the most
difficult thing we're facing is people
want us to well collect those so we can
bring them up and study them actually
retrieving samples from those incredible
depths is actually really difficult
because the Machinery that you would
need to do that doesn't function very
well under those extreme conditions but
we have made some attempts and have had
some limited success and what sort of
we've spoken about the the high
pressures what sort of pressures are we
talking about that depth
you're talking about 16 000 pounds per
square inch so if you actually took the
entire surface area of the submersible
that we operate in it would be
equivalent to four USS Nimitz aircraft
carriers with their aircraft sitting on
top of the submersible it's just a
tremendous amount of pressure or four
automobiles on your fingernail something
like that and that pressure will find
the weakest point of any mechanical
device and destroy it so we're going to
talk about your submersible in just a
moment but Helen I just want to go back
because there's actually some
theorizing that life on planet Earth may
have begun in the hydrothermal band so
it may not just be a wonderful anomalous
Arena where life can unexpectedly Thrive
it may be that life started there so so
what is the thinking on that
so yeah it's a theory it's been around
for a few decades now and we're getting
pieces of of
um supporting evidence and studies that
are being done to kind of back this up
but the I this kind of the basic idea is
that well as long as
um pretty much as long as the Earth has
existed there's been an ocean that came
along pretty quickly and those ever
since we've had an ocean we've had
hydrothermal vents it's a geological
process that's been going on and on so
so there have been Vents and um and the
idea is that within these structures
Within These these chimneys that form by
the deposition of these these metals
that are coursing out of the um the
deeper parts of the the Earth's mantle
um are potentially
um structures that that maybe set up the
conditions that are needed that would
have been needed for the first sign the
first living cells to exist basically
this this think of it like a very fine
honeycomb structure within these
chimneys and um and the theory is that
on a very particular type of
hydrothermal vent not actually on these
really hot boiling hot ones that they're
200 300 degrees Celsius ones that's
unlikely it probably would have just
boiled the first signs of life into some
kind of soup but there are cooler ones
and and in particular there are ones
that are a bit more alkaline
um and and that's important because what
we're talking about
um the nitty-gritty of it is the idea of
setting up
um gradients of protons uh um the the
molecules that are going to power
um the Machinery of life
um could potentially have been set up
within these these physical structures
might have been almost like the first
Proto cells it's just a theory
um there are amazing scientists who are
looking into this who are building their
own own hydrothermal vent Chimneys in
Laboratories seeing what happens and
they have had some success in in finding
that some of these very early building
blocks of life do assemble themselves in
these kind of conditions
um so you know this is a possibility
we've also found some very very old
um fossilized remains or what could have
been fossilized remains a very early
bacterial microbial life because that's
what this would have been we're looking
at trying to make or when were the first
you know single-celled living cells
created when when were they that when
did they spark into life and it could
have been
um from these kinds of deposits we're
finding in very ancient hydrotherm from
very ancient hydrothermal events
um we don't know yet we may never know
um but it's exciting it's a possibility
and it I think it brings us back to this
idea of those parallels of looking up
into space and looking down into the
Inner Space of the ocean there are other
hydrothermal vents in the rest of uh of
our galaxy
um
on
um other other celestial bodies there
are oceans we think and there could well
be hydrogen events down there so who
knows maybe there's maybe there's life
there too it's a possibility yeah in
fact that was exactly the question where
I I wanted to go which is you know Vicky
when one thinks about the origin of
these events I gather it's various
disjunctures of pieces of the mantle as
they're they're rubbing across each
other and allowing for the molten
material underneath to to seep through
should we expect that to be a kind of
ubiquitous phenomenon on on other bodies
in the solar system in the galaxy
I mean I think that that's uh a widely
held expectation and that's part of the
reason that a lot of development is
being done on the kinds of technology
that can help us get there and make
those kinds of observations yeah so if
that's the case Victor it means that all
the work that you're doing to dive to
the depths here may have an application
on on other worlds at some point but
before we get there let's turn to the
work that you've done on this world
where you know you've been this
incredible Pioneer in building this
extraordinary vessel that you've made
reference to which is a real game
changer so I'm wondering if you can just
take us through
what it was that drove you and what it
is that you created with your team to be
able to have this reusable submersible
to go to the as you say the deepest
parts of planet Earth
yeah I think you can see uh the
schematics up there on the screen I love
the front shot where it actually shows
the windows it looks like it's in this
constant state of surprise which I think
is an apt a metaphor for what it's like
when you're actually diving down there
but I think at certain times in history
Technologies develop in parallel where
if you put all the pieces together you
can make something truly extraordinary
whether it be the first aircraft or the
first firearmer or heaven knows what but
I think in this particular case we were
able to have the Technologies come
together combined with my observation
back in 2015 that I just looked around
and was looking for a different type of
Adventure and said goodness gracious no
human has ever been to the bottom of
four of our world's oceans it's kind of
about time that that happened because we
had the technology to go to the bottom
of the Mariana Trench we had proven that
but the pieces hadn't been put together
to enable a device that could allow you
to go to all the oceans repeatedly
safely
and so I just decided to try and see if
we could do that so I was able to
partner with Trident submarines in their
brilliant designers John Ramsey and Tom
blades and through a lot of trial and
error and a lot of fixing of the
Technologies as we did the five deep
Expedition we were able to put this
entire system together not just the
submersible but a full ocean depth sonar
mounted on the ship as Vicki mentioned
to map where we would go because we
didn't even know where the bottom of
four of the world's oceans exactly were
and so we had to go find them and then
dive them but then there were also full
ocean death capable Landers which were
basically robots that would go down with
the submersible and act as navigation
beacons on the bottom because GPS
doesn't work underwater so we had to
develop a whole system of tracking the
submersible as it went on involved style
so as a conglomeration of a lot of
different technologies that we were able
to affect but that's really what drives
me in terms of passion is trying to
develop new technologies to advance this
forward and yeah I would die a happy man
if some of the technologies that we've
developed on these Expeditions were
later used so on expeditions to Europa
or ganymy to penetrate the ice layers of
these moons and actually find the first
true extraterrestrial life so the heart
of your submersible I gather is a
titanium sphere that you built in order
to withstand the incredible pressure
that you made reference to before so so
why titanium and and why is fear and and
how precisely did it need to be
spherical in its geometry
you know the real heart of the
submersible it was a 90 millimeters
thick titanium sphere titanium is a
wonderful material because it's half the
weight of Steel twice as strong the only
problem is it's very expensive and it's
very difficult to machine but as a
sphere it was perfectly designed to
handle the pressure in fact under
intense pressure it actually compresses
about three or four millimeters so it
becomes even stronger at depth as long
as there's not a penetration of the
viewports or the hatch with some water
so it's incredibly strong design and it
had to be machined down to point zero
one percent perfect curiosity to make it
work so there would be no deformations
that would allow that pressure to over
time cause an anomaly that could cause
it to have a problem
and and so
um were you the first yeah there it is
you can see it right there is forged in
Wisconsin under intense heat and then
being hammered into the two hemispheres
that we then bolted together which you
can see there putting the viewports is
the tough part because there you have an
acrylic kind of cone that allows us to
see out but wherever you have dissimilar
materials that can cause potential
stresses that could complicate things
and and and so how did you test this to
make sure at those incredible pressures
it would actually work
the only thing we could test at full
ocean depth was actually the sphere
itself which is the most important
component and there you can see it being
lowered into the largest full ocean
depth test chamber in the world which is
in the cryov Institute in St Petersburg
Russia I don't think anyone has access
to it anymore but we were fortunate we
did this several years ago and we
subjected it to 14
000 meters of water pressure and it
passed with flying colors and with that
we knew we had a system that could at
least keep the pilots alive and safe and
then we went to building all the other
components the thrusters the batteries
and all these other things in separate
conditions and then try to put it all
together and having that system
integration of making everything work
that was the real trick but we've been
able to perfect it over the last two or
three years and when you climb into that
and sometimes I guess two of you climb
into that I gather it's a what what in
the world
is is is that like I mean um it just
feels incredibly claustrophobic but but
do you meditation in the right place
yeah if you're claustrophobic you don't
want to get in there because some of our
missions can be 14 hours long but uh the
best analogy I have is that it's like
sitting in the cockpit of a Business Jet
it's not uncomfortable but it is
relatively constrained and there's
really nowhere to go you can't go use a
restroom outside so you do have to train
yourself that you're going to be
comfortable sitting in a seat maybe even
stretching a little bit here and there
on a 12 to 14 hour mission
and knowing that you've gone down with
has freaked out at all it's all been
smooth no I typically take people inside
this submersible first and even we'll
close the hatch to get a sense for what
their mental state is and if they are in
any way claustrophobic and we do
actually medically evaluate people
before they get in the submersible with
me but I guess if anyone really ever
freaked out and we were two or three
hours from the surface you know the way
around that is you just slowly you know
decrease the oxygen level and they'll go
to sleep
that's a that's a good approach yeah
absolutely so so so Vicky you know I
know that there's been some
um recent excitement about the Deep
trenches that Victor has explored giving
us I guess a clearer sense of of how
deep they are and and exactly what the
Topography is like what what have we
learned recently about those trenches
well I think you know just the very
Basics the foundation of what the depth
of these trenches really is and what the
shape of the seafloor around it is I was
just looking at some of the data from
Victor ship just last week and there are
all sorts of details that we really
wouldn't be able to see I'm not sure how
uh readily people know that you know
most of the maps that we see of the
ocean floor are based primarily on
prediction of depth so besides the 24
that we know has been mapped with direct
measurement the remaining 76 percent is
um it's really based on predicted
bathymetry derived from a model that
uses gravity and the the elevation of
the sea surface
and so that gives us a crude estimation
of the shape of the seafloor it can be
up to I've seen instances where it's
more than a kilometer and a half
different from the actual observed depth
once we actually take a sonar there so
um and this is because of the very the
the factors that affect the gravity of
uh various parts of of the planet and so
as we get more and more measurements it
really is akin to bringing the seafloor
into Focus right it goes from a sort of
blurry diffuse lumpy shape into
something that's really crisp and
detailed and we can see striations we
can see all sorts of morphology that
just was not detectable before and so
will this contribute to your project
that you're involved with seabed 2030 I
mean maybe you can give us a quick sense
of what that project is and how these
Explorations May contribute to it
yeah so uh the project itself has the
very ambitious goal of mapping 100 of
the ocean floor by the year 2030. uh the
project started about five years ago
and we're really trying to build a
global coalition to bring everyone
together who has the the technology to
collect this kind of data who might have
this data in hand but hasn't been aware
of the potential to share it and
contribute to This Global effort the
mission of the project that was set
forward collaboratively by the Nippon
foundation in Japan and jebco which is
an intergovernmental project really is
to empower the world to make sustainable
decisions and good policy decisions and
to support science throughout the ocean
again the resolutions that we're aiming
for to complete our goals are still
relatively coarse by some perspectives
but compared to what we have right now
which is prediction at you know several
hundred meters resolution it's
significantly better and it will open
the door to all sorts of discoveries and
hopefully also you know important
management so that we are good stewards
of the ocean yeah and and Helen when you
think about these
see voyages
are you planning on on going have you
signed up for for victory submersible
and what would you hope to learn for
your particular line of research
so I have not been invited on Victor oh
is that not for me
I'm not happy to hear from you too but
Helen is how I was asking that question
I'll put my name on the list for sure um
right I guess what absolutely
um I guess one thing that I've been
doing especially in my writing and then
when I talk about the deep and trying to
get
um as many people as possible to to know
about it and Care a bit more about it
um you know it is this place that's so
far out of sight and out of mind for
just about everybody else so so the
challenge is to you know how to
um excite people and and capture
people's imaginations about this place
and that's why
um what Victor is doing is so important
because no matter how clever our
machines are and how incredible this
technology we have which is so important
and it's telling us so much there's such
a power of putting a human being in that
place and and it's the stories that that
can bring
um same as space in another wonderful
parallel to space we don't have to have
human beings up there but oh my goodness
aren't those stories more compelling
when they are so so that's why I think
you know it's
it's such a a rich kind of vein to to
understanding as well this is our you
know this is our planet this is our
living planet just because us humans
can't without this incredible technology
survive down there
um doesn't mean it isn't a part of this
extraordinary interconnected system of
life in which we all depend so um
whoever gets to go they're all the
luckiest people
um and one of the wonderful things that
Victor is doing um which she hasn't
mentioned is that he's bringing all
sorts of different people into these
incredible places and giving
opportunities
um to people from for example around the
Pacific Ocean where a lot of these
amazing trenches are taking those people
who live in these places to see the very
bottom part of their ocean is so
powerful and so important all of those
people are going to come back and tell
stories and hopefully
um you know help to spread their word of
why this matters and what is down there
and it isn't just this
um empty space but it's an extraordinary
diverse
um geology geography and biology of our
planet it's all down there so uh so yeah
put sign me on the list but you know I
think the list is quite long so yeah
unfortunately if I can add real quick
one big question that's often asked is
why have a human occupied vehicle done
there why not just use robots it's a
simple question but actually it's a
complicated answer when you're talking
about going to the very very bottom of
the ocean it's seven miles down or
eleven thousand meters so even a
remotely operated vehicle would have a
heck of a tether above it and many times
these tethers are so long that it's not
practical to actually recover them and
they're just ejected into the ocean and
can actually become big sort of
pollution the most amount of pollution
I've seen in the Challenger Deep is
actually these discarded cables then
people go why don't I just use a robot
that's autonomous well they can't
dynamically interact with the
environment for example those same
tethers that are a bit of a pollution
problem also can actually entangle the
thrusters on an autonomous vehicle and
they may not even see them and therefore
get entangled human occupied Vehicles
can go to any depth they can interact
directly with the environment avoid
obstacles immediately investigate things
that are interesting so they all have
their different role to play and I think
that manned submersibles actually have
unique advantages for the ultra deep
ocean that robotic vehicles have some
difficulties with yeah no that's an
important point and I'm glad you make
that and I want to turn to the pollution
issue in just a moment before we get
there I just want to ask you Victor one
question when we think about big
projects of this sort usually one thinks
government support you know Academia
government grants things of that sort
but but the funding for this I gather
came and comes from from you as an
individual is that correct
yeah I funded all of it and and so uh
first of all that's absolutely amazing
and I think the world owes you uh debt
of gratitude for doing so but what kind
of cost are we talking if you don't mind
I'm just I have no idea
sure talking in the public domain but in
general it took about 50 million to
actually develop and produce the entire
system and then to take it on its first
series of expeditions but I think the
reason why government didn't do this was
that there just wasn't a huge impetus to
build such a vessel to do this mission
of Discovery there isn't a lot of
economic potential in the deep ocean so
there wasn't a commercial interest this
is just something I thought that needed
to be done and anything that is be done
by a government can often take a lot
more time and a lot more money if you
just looked at the US government has
spent probably twice as much what I
spent on this entire system and
expedition to increase the maximum depth
of its own government-owned submersible
the Alvin from 5 500 minutes to 6 500
meters so I mean what's the old joke
right uh a male I'm sorry an elephant is
a mouse built to government
specifications and it's just the nature
of government that it requires a lot
more input a lot more time a lot more
oversight and that just Edge time and
time is money Etc but in our case it was
a very small very capable team there was
one person paying for it who also was
the pilot and was helping design it so
that just provided an extremely
efficient Loop to troubleshoot and
design and build a system and perfect it
and you take scientists down and I
gather the data is made available to
everyone
yeah everything we do I put out there is
open source there's no commercial
interest in this whatsoever even our
media is self-produced and we just put
it out there on YouTube so everything is
open source and as wonderful so I want
to turn as a final topic
to the issue that you made reference to
to issues of pollution and what's down
there I mean I I gather during one of
your Dives in the in some deep ocean
trench you found like plastic bag or
something like that and that was even
just the most visible sign of pollution
but it's actually much more pernicious
than than just a bag right but I have
seen plastic bags at upped up I found a
teddy bear in the Philippine trench at
more than ten thousand meters looking
back at me which was a little disturbing
but there is a lot of human
contamination but the most pernicious
problem we face in the oceans is not the
that the tridents that you can see it's
the microplastics if there's one thing
that I've learned is that plastic cannot
touch the ocean ever as soon as it does
it will begin to break down in those
microplastics will get into the ocean
and be diffused throughout the entire
ocean system and there's no removing it
and so therefore it really has to be an
initiative just to prevent plastic from
Ever Getting in the ocean in the first
place if you really want to save the
food chain and Helen do you see evidence
of that kind of of pollution in in your
work
oh absolutely I mean you're quite right
that it just gets everywhere I mean in
Plastics of course the microplastics get
into the deep ocean and there's so many
studies showing just how badly I mean
some of the worst polluted places that
have been measured uh for instance off
um coast of Italy there have been um
sediments there we think that's there
are kind of almost like Sandstorm
currents that are concentrating these
things but some of the highest
concentration of microplastics there are
a hundred thousand pieces falling on the
area of equivalent to the size of open
pages of a book
um it's phenomenal I mean it's it's
phenomenal what's getting down there
it's entering the sedimentary kind of
geological record cause of this stuff
are being pulled up pulled out of the
seabed you know our Mark is there this
is this the stamp of the anthropocene is
in the deep in the ocean in the bottom
of the sea
um for sure
um the question that we're on picking
now is a kind of a Global Science
Community is what kind of impact is that
having ecologically
um and uh you know I guess just a couple
of years ago I might have said oh well
we don't really know and you know we're
waiting to see the impact beyond the
individual
um but I think more the more we look the
more it's terrifying it becomes that
these microplastics as as we know are
getting inside organisms they're getting
inside of humans every single shark
that's been looked at it's got plastic
in its stomach plastic is getting
everywhere and it is having an effect on
individuals and that is being passed up
throughout ecosystems and food chains
and and in your book beyond I mean
obviously this is the perhaps the
deepest of problems the micro passes but
in terms of things that perhaps have
more visual impact in your book you give
a list and a kind of astounding list of
things that have been dumped in into the
I mean what what are what's on that list
right so I mean one of the things that
humans have done um historically is to
look at the oceans and go well that's a
great resource simply for how big it is
and how we can put things there and not
have to think about it anymore because
they'll just hide it away so
um uh not so long ago it was common
practice just to put human sewage onto
ships onto barges take it offshore and
Chuck it in the sea there's a there's a
couple of particular dump sites off the
coast of uh the east coast of North
America off of New York which
um went down there I mean and that in
itself isn't necessarily
um you know human waste isn't isn't the
worst thing you can put in the ocean
it's more I mean the things that that
are are kind of shocking and and more
alarming is is the long history of
dumping basically rotting chemical
weapons
um that kind of thing and there's a huge
big um sort of cover-up that happened in
the United States and it wasn't just the
United States you know most military
nations were doing the same thing they
were filling ships with with old uh
canisters of of uh and chemical weapons
um nerve gases that they weren't going
to use or that were going out of date
most of them offshore and and sink the
ships down into bits of the ocean the
really scary thing is we don't really
know where those are
um where those dump sites are you know
it's classified or we don't actually
know anymore you know this was happening
kind of 50s 60s 70s it led to what now
is the case that you can't do that
anymore there are now International
treaties that say there's only a few
things you can dump in the deep ocean
and and it's definitely not huge
quantities of terrible chemicals but
where those chemicals lie and what kind
of impact they're having is um is a big
mystery we occasionally coming across
them one was not so long ago found at
dumps I found off um the coast of Los
Angeles I think but the question is what
do we do about it are we going to bring
them up we're going to put down some
concrete to cover them over what can we
do something like a million tons we
think of chemical weapons are down there
um somewhere in the deep ocean but uh
where exactly we don't know
um but yeah I mean also enormous
quantities of um domestic animals if
those ships containing uh live uh sheep
and other
um animals that are ship across the
world for different markets if they get
into trouble and animals don't see they
get put over the side so that's good
news for the bone-eating worms I think
they have a good Feast when that happens
um and you know maybe in the big scheme
of things not such a big deal
um but you can you can find that at the
history of humanity really written out
across the seabed their shipping routes
with lumps of of clinker the stuff that
got chucked off the side of of
steamships um the the residues from
burning coal
um was stuck over the side of of the
ships into the deep sea and you can find
these you know for for a long time to
come you'll be able to work out what
Humanity was up to by going and looking
down in the deep ocean Vicky you too
you've expressed regarding your own work
that
a downside potential downside of mapping
the seabed is that it could ultimately
contribute to overfishing in in those
domains is that is that a concern that
you still have
well you know I think that as we reveal
more of this uh environment that has
really been hidden from us and in many
ways protected from us it's definitely a
concern to think about how that
information will be used and potentially
exploited and certainly not within my
domain to figure out how to handle that
and I can certainly say with uh with
great conviction that most of what we
need to do to understand and Steward the
planet and the ocean starts with a map
so I think having the map is a really
important First Step but I am hopeful
that the concerns about how that content
that data is used is elevated to the
right International bodies to make sure
that we do a good job of stewarding our
ocean and helping to protect the
valuable resources that are there Victor
with so much of the deep ocean lying
Beyond National boundaries in some sense
that means that those areas belong to no
one in some sense therefore they belong
to everyone do you and does that cause
difficulties for you as an Explorer does
it does it cause difficulties for
regulating the kinds of activities that
might one day those errors might want to
be subject to
absolutely
we commiserate among ourselves the
private operators of oceanographic
research teams and the number one issue
that is the barrier to deep ocean
exploration is actually not the
technology it's not the funding it's not
the availability Personnel it's
government permitting
government bureaucrats around the world
have an instinctive
reaction to say no to a lot of marine
scientific research or it takes
many many months or even years to get
permitted to do this in their exclusive
economic events which is these colored
areas that you see on the map there the
other areas are what they call the high
seas where there basically is no
regulation and there's no legal
Authority there is no U.N police force
that polices the world's oceans it is
the wild west so one thing that I
discovered in going around the world
several times in the last four years
trying to do Marine research is that
some governments are quite hostile you
probably can guess who those countries
are other countries are incredibly
welcoming and love the fact that we're
doing open source dissemination of the
data that we uncover and so that's been
the most frustrating part of ocean
exploration for me personally has just
been trying to navigate the very
difficult bureaucratic barriers to
oceanographic research and sometimes
getting in trouble after the fact for
doing research that should have been
freely allowed
so Victor one final topic before we wrap
up you you emphasize that there's no
commercial
impetus for the kinds of deep sea Dives
and yet I I have read that there are
some who disagree and think that there
is a a commercial use and there is even
chatter about
attempts to mine the ocean floor for
various kinds of metals that would be
used in various Technologies where do
you think that all stands
well there's certain our materials at
the bottom of the sea floor particularly
in poly metallic nodules in certain
areas of the seabed that have some rare
materials like Cobalt and manganese and
others that could be valuable I think
there are two Dimensions to that that I
think are problematic one is that I
think economically it's going to be much
much more difficult to bring them up in
commercial quantities than they realize
as someone who has operated a great deal
at extreme depth I think they've grossly
underestimate the breakage that they'll
have of their Machinery that's supposed
to operate 24 7. it's in an incredibly
hostile environment and when it breaks
you're going to have to bring it all the
way back up fix it and put it back down
so I think economically they're being
very very optimistic and it probably
won't work at least as the businessman
May thinks that the second is the
ecological damage that strip mining the
sea floor will likely have and I don't
think there's much doubt at all that
they'll just destroy these ecosystems
there's an argument that they will
recover but I can speak specific
typically about that because last year
we went to the wreck of the USS Johnston
which was a military warship that hit
the bottom and then slid down about 400
meters at very much the same depths
where they're contemplating Mining and
what we directly observed is that the
gouges that this warship made on the sea
floor were exactly the same as they
probably were when it went down 78 years
ago there was no real recovery and we
have published a peer-reviewed
scientific paper making evidence of that
fact so I think they're also in some
respects not really welcoming that
information now if you wound the sea
floor to such an incredibly High degree
it could take hundreds or even thousands
of years for it to recover so is it
really worth it I mean Vicky are you
worried that the calculus that Victor
describes might encourage some perhaps
through an errant calculation to give it
a shot go down there and attempt to mine
and in that way erect the kind of
Destruction that that Victor envisions
would happen
I think it's a pretty complicated
operation to try to run as Victor said
so I don't think that it would be a very
easy thing for someone to just try
um I'm hopeful that conversations about
regulation and uh really how to approach
this in a responsible way will yield
some fruitful outcomes uh you know
personally I think it's as Victor said
you know the ecological concerns are
really tremendous and so we have to be
very cautious about how we enter and
engage with these environments because
they have been protected from us for so
long and particularly in a time where
the human impact on the planet is
becoming more and more evident every day
we hopefully will take pause and as we
step into this deep world that we are
starting to be able to reach more more
uh routinely be better stewards and
really be cautious of what damage we
might be causing and when it comes to
mining are there
particular
entities objects things that some in the
community might consider to be the
treasures the things that would drive
them to undertake these difficult and
potentially destructive missions to the
ocean floor
um yeah
[Music]
mining companies that exactly doing one
of these these Rocky nodules these poly
metallic nodules they look a bit like
lumps of coal spread across various
areas of the abyss and these contain
various different metals they form
incredibly slowly we think it's one of
the slowest geological processes that's
ever been studied
um uh they you know they they grow over
millions of years from a little piece of
something sometimes like an ancient
shark tooth drops to the seabed that
forms the nucleus on which um metals and
other compounds from the water chemicals
from the water will settle out and
precipitate onto these rocks and that is
the basis for for what we know now know
to be rich ecosystems all sorts of
species Coral sponges grow on these
things other things rely on them it's
it's like
um the equivalent of old growth trees in
a forest in terms of the role that those
nodules play in the ecosystem so that's
one big Target people are looking at
um the others are the Chimneys in
hydrothermal vents those black smokers
also contain a whole bunch of different
Metals it they vary depending on where
you look
um so that's um of great interest and
then almost kind of midway between the
two
um there are tens of thousands if not
millions of enormous mountains sea
mounts hidden down in the ocean their
peaks don't rise to the surface but they
can be many miles tall and a lot of
those have got crust on them as well
which are metal rich in metals a similar
sort of process to the formation of
those nodules very slow
um but again the idea for that and this
is a big a bigger engineering challenge
would be to basically kind of scrape off
the tops of some of these
um often flat topped seamounts have got
these deposits on them but growing on
top of that stuff are these rich forests
made of thousand-year-old corals and all
the other animals that rely on those in
this Rich ecosystem is there too so all
of these three places that people are
looking at mining uh sure they're rich
the treasures the mineral Treasures are
there but also the they're full of
biological Treasures too and when it
comes to say that the metals in
particular minerals what do people
imagine doing with whatever they is that
they might successfully mine one day
and so I mean this
right now
and
many of the the organizations who who
perhaps stand potentially financially to
gain from this are telling us that well
we need these Metals for the Green
Revolution and this is the big argument
that's being made that a lot of these
metals are key components for electric
car batteries for
um various renewable energy generation
devices storage devices and so forth
um and uh on the flip side of that being
that the the land-based resources of
these metals are becoming less uh
accessible
um there are projections to when those
might run down when we might need more
of them all of that is really subjective
many different unknowns and many
different uh difficult the difficulty of
predicting what we're going to need how
much we're going to need as a global
society and when we're going to need it
is it's not straightforward I mean for
instance you know there are Technologies
being developed in which car batteries
don't require Cobalts one of these
Metals we could be getting from the deep
ocean
um it's it's not clear-cut but but
that's what we that's that's the
argument that's being built is that this
is is critical to to see ourselves
towards a green future
difficult to know what kind of impact
it's going to have on uh the weight uh
the way in which the deep ocean is
actually storing carbon and playing that
key role in in the climate itself and
could be making it worse simply by
mining the deep sea that's also a big
question we need a good answer for
before we go ahead and do this and Helen
are you ultimately optimistic about how
we will be stewards of the oceans and
the seafloor
um I I'm optimistic that there's a lot
of different voices now and a lot of
strong voices
um you know two of them right here um
who we've been speaking to today who are
making really sensible
um analysis of of that particular use of
the deep ocean in terms of Mining and a
lot of other
um brilliant people are coming out and
really thinking carefully about this and
the question is is everyone else going
to listen to these people who who know
that who know this space who are
studying it who've been there who have
seen you know why it matters so much
that we look after the entirety of our
ocean not just the bits that we can see
um but then yeah on the bad days when
I'm not feeling so positive I remember
that it is all out of sight and it is
going to be easy for us to or for some
people potentially to to go and uh and
cause huge damage
um that we won't see you know it's not
the same in terms of mining on land
where you know even that can be kind of
out of the way but you know we have
satellite imagery we have drones we have
the ability to stand back and look at
that Mountaintop that's been been raised
based we won't get that in the deep
ocean not so easily I mean maybe we can
and maybe maybe Vicky's can help us to
show that nothing can actually be hidden
in the deep and and whatever happens
down there will have a consequence uh it
will have a consequence but one that we
can see
so I think there's a balance to be
struck
um it really is an important time to
realize that everything is connected and
the more we look in the Deep the more we
see that from the mountaintops to the
deepest parts of the ocean these places
that Victor has been to all of them
you're not the only connection between
them but you're you're following these
lines of energy of food of of the way
our planet works and it's all connected
together and if we break one piece of it
then it's not going to be good yeah
absolutely so one final question for all
of you uh maybe start with you Helen in
the best of all worlds 15 20 25 years
from now where would you like your
research to be what what do you what
what's the big goal that you'd be
thrilled to accomplish and say the next
quarter century
in terms of well what I do which is I
know a lot of my focus is is is getting
the word out to people and and finding
ways of telling these stories to as many
people as possible about about the ocean
and it wouldn't be my doing but what I
hope I could do in 25 years time is to
go and tell everyone that we didn't
go and do these things that Humanity did
decide that there are places on this
planet and the deep ocean is one of them
that is too important too untouched not
completely untouched but um but you know
some of the most uh you know untouched
places on our planet and we decided to
leave them alone and do things
differently that for me you know so it
I'm gonna play a tiny part in that
actually happening but I would love to
be a part of of telling that story you
know to the to the Future Generations
the people who are going to be the ones
dealing with all of this um down the
line
um that's what I'd like to see Vicky how
about you well uh one of the things that
excites me the most is that uh I am
contributing to creating the first
complete map of our planet right so if
the ocean covers the majority of the
planet and it's not been mapped yet we
really don't have a map of our planet
that's one thing the other thing really
is to help build connection for people
to the ocean and I think we can do that
very effectively through data the data
that we collect not just of the shape of
the sea floor but the data that we
collect with robotic vehicles and with
submersibles from going there and
getting eyes on the seafloor really
build that connection so that people
understand that the ocean affects
everyone on the planet and I'm also
hopeful that at the end of the UN decade
that's underway right now which is the
U.N decade of ocean science for
sustainable development we will have
come together as a global Community to
make impact and help move us in a better
direction towards stewarding the ocean
absolutely Victor I'm going to give you
the final word look you've been to the
mountaintops you've been to space you've
been down deep in the ocean is the ocean
your final frontier or is there
something else completely different that
you're going to be doing 10 15 20 years
from now
could be anything I love flying I love
space I love the oceans hopefully I'll
be doing a mixture of all three but I
think that what I'm very happy about is
that I've helped the spearhead a lot of
the technological development to make
the oceans more transparent Keen beings
are visual creatures and uh I think that
anything we can do to create more
transparency the oceans will make people
care about them or understand them more
and therefore in 25 years I'm hoping
that going down to the bottom of the
ocean will be straightforward and we'll
be able to much more easily collect
specimens from any part of the seafloor
map it in even greater detail and have a
much harder Nord but deeper
understanding of everything that happens
in the oceans and not just in the easily
accessible areas near the surface but
the entirety of the oceans and with that
I have no doubt will cause greater
understanding of how it works in terms
of climate biology and every other
aspect that will help us survive here on
Earth absolutely so I wish you the best
of luck all of you and the work that
you're going to undertake and have it
undertaking and to Riff on Victor's last
adjective thank you so much for this
deeply informative conversation about
the ocean depth thank you so much
[Music]
thank you